[MUSIC PLAYING]
[? XAVIER DUCOY: ?] Hello.
Good afternoon.
My name is Xavier [? Ducoy. ?]
JEROME DOCHEZ: And my
name is Jerome Dochez.
[? XAVIER DUCOY: ?]
So today we're
going to talk about
what's new in the Android
build system since last year.
We're going to start
with variant aware
dependency management.
So it shipped last year
in 3.0 in the fall.
And, you know, the
whole concept is
that all the
variants of a module
can depend on matching
variant in another model,
so debug depends on
debug in the library
and release depends
on release, and it
works well as long
as you have matching
variants on both sides.
But when it doesn't happen,
even though we have a DSL
to help you fix the
problem, but we've
seen a lot of developers
over the last six,
nine months who just
see an error message
like this and just don't
know what to do with it.
So we wanted to
take a few minutes
to explain exactly
what's going on
and help you solve
such a problem.
So the first thing to
look at is this line
that says could not
resolve project library.
So that's the project that
publishes the artifact
that you're trying to consume.
And the project
that's consuming it
is the one that says
required by project app.
And in the top
right section, you
can see it says the name of
the configuration that we
are trying to resolve, which
is staging runtime class pass.
And it's always the name
of the variant followed
by compiler run time,
followed by class pass,
so here, it's the
runtime class pass.
And the error is unable to
find a matching configuration.
And so the way it's
working, really,
is that the library
project is publishing
a whole bunch of artifacts
for different variants
in different configurations,
and each of those configurations
has attributes associated with
it so that Gradle can match it.
On the app side, the request
has similar attributes,
and it's trying to
do a mapping, and it
needs to find an exact match.
And here, it can't
find any match.
So if you go through
those for configuration,
you can look at
all the attributes,
and basically, by
process of elimination,
find out what the problem is.
So here, the first thing
that we see is two of them
have an API--
their API used by
compile class pass--
and the other two are runtime.
And you can see that the
attribute name usage, we
request Java runtime, and some
of them are using Java API,
so they are not compatible,
so we can just ignore them.
Then we have a few
more attributes.
There's one here,
android type attribute,
that is compatible
on both sides,
so we can just ignore it.
It's something that
we use internally
to match different type
of plug-in application
versus library versus features,
so you can just ignore it.
The other one, variant
attribute, is not required.
It's actually never
required, and you can just
ignore it always.
We use that only when
we build the model when
we do a studio sync.
So you can always ignore it.
And then we find
the final attribute,
which is always incompatible.
We ask for staging, and it's
finding two other values.
And the name or type
of the attribute here,
which is package name.build
type attribute, is the key part.
It's basically, hopefully,
self-explanatory.
This is the build
type attribute,
and we're requesting staging,
and it's not finding it.
So basically, it means
your library does not
have the staging build type,
and that's why it's failing.
So you can't trade it
there, or you can just
use the DSL that allows
you to create a fallback.
So in that case here
on the app, you're
saying if staging is not
sound, just use debug.
You have the same
exact principle
if you have a missing
flavor dimension value.
Here, the error message
is a little bit different
because there's
multiple flavors,
potentially, so they're named--
tier being the name of
the flavor dimension--
but that's the same
problem, right?
It's not finding trial when
you're searching for it,
and so the fix is basically
exactly the same one.
You're just assigning matching
fallback on the trial run,
and we do that on the
consuming side, right?
On the app side,
not the library.
Or if it's a library that
depends on the library,
you put it always on
the consuming side.
You can have another
type of problem.
Here, it's saying cannot
choose between the following
configuration.
So instead of
finding zero matches,
it finds two compatible
matches, and so it's only
going to show the two
configurations that
are matching.
It's going to hide
all the other ones,
so that's a little bit easier.
And if you look at
it, there's going
to be a lot of attributes
that are compatible,
so you can just ignore them.
And then you're down
to those two here,
and it says it found an
attribute on the producing
side on the library, but it was
not required by the consumer.
And so here, basically
what's happening
is that your library has defined
a flavor dimension that is not
defined in the app or
the consuming module,
and therefore, it doesn't
know how to choose this one.
So you can, again, create the
flavor dimension in your app
or in the consuming model,
or you can just go and say
missing dimension strategy, name
of the flavor dimension, name
of the value, and
all it's doing,
really, is just adding
that attribute directly
to the request so that it's
able to match the other one.
And you can add these either
to the default config, which
applies to all your
variants, you kind apply it
to a specific flavor, which
will apply only to that flavor,
or you can add it to
a particular variant.
JEROME DOCHEZ: All
right, so let's
talk about some of
the notable changes
that we've introduced in
the compilation pipeline.
The first thing that we
have changed lately is aapt,
and this is a new incremental
resource compiler.
And compared to aapt1, aapt2
is really dividing its work
into two phases.
There is an incremental
capable compilation
phase, where it's changing your
resources into a binary format,
and then there is a
final linking phase
where it's going to
generate the resource
table and the final IDs.
Now, if you want to use the
latest platform features,
you need to use aapt2.
And in theory, aapt2 is
entirely compatible with aapt1.
However, it's a lot stricter, so
you might run into issues when
you change from aapt1 to appt2.
So we have given you
a flag so that you
can disable if you
have issues, but you
should be aware that
those issues may not
be in aapt2 itself.
It may be in your project.
So you should find bugs if
you find issues with aapt2,
but you should do
your homework first.
You should look
into, well, maybe
the problem is in my project.
So let's look.
Maybe you have invalid resources
and reference to stuff.
aapt2 will catch those.
So we're going to phase
out aapt1 pretty soon,
so it's really important
that you switch
and that you find bugs
if you still find some.
Next thing is desugar.
So this is a tool
which is used to remove
all the syntactic sugar
that was added by Java 8,
like [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that.
We've delivered, again,
into two different versions.
So the first version
we shipped was 3.0,
was an external process.
It used a lot of
resource, was pretty slow.
Now with the D8,
the new Dexer, we've
introduced a newer
version where it's
integrated inside its pipeline,
so it's better, it's faster.
Again, we're going to
phase out the old version.
In theory, you should all be
switching to the integrated
version.
You shouldn't be
seeing any difference.
If you do, please file a bug.
It's most likely
our fault this time.
It's probably not your
fault. But file a bug
because we're going to phase
out the old external process
version very soon.
Talking about Dexer,
you should all
be using the new D8
compiler right now.
It was introduced in 3.0.
It's now default in 3.1.
If you use DX--
if you still use DX because you
have errors, translation errors
or runtime errors, you
should definitely file bugs.
They are extremely responsive
at fixing those issues.
And again, we're going to
be phasing out the old DX
very soon, and we
would like you to be
still capable of building
your applications,
so please file bugs.
Now, we've just introduced
R8, which is a new shrinker
obfuscator, but it's a slightly
different thing than what
it used to be, was ProGuard.
So ProGuard used to
operate on class files.
It was transforming class
files and making them minified
to be ready to be dexed.
R8 takes over the entire
pipeline from class files
to text files, so that
means it's doing desugar,
it's doing minification, and
dexing all in one operation,
and it can reuse a lot of
the data, so it's faster.
So we introduced it.
You should try it, and you
should see if it works well.
Again, please file bugs
because at some point,
we will stop supporting the
old shrinkers-- maybe not soon,
but very mid-term, I would say.
Now, these are the flags you
can use to enable or disable
R8 and D8, so please use
these if you run into trouble,
but please also file bugs, OK?
Now let's talk a little
bit about performance.
We know very well that it is a
subject that you are extremely
interested in, and so are we.
One of the problems
we have is that we
have a lot of trouble
reproducing issues
that may happen in the wild.
We don't have that
many applications
internally that we can use.
However, here is an example
using the Nest mobile app.
And you can see that a Nest full
build has improved about 13%
from 3.0 to 3.1, and about 18%--
obviously this is not final--
with 3.2 versus 3.1.
That's if you keep the
same set of features
in your application.
Obviously you're not
changing the application,
just changing the plug-in.
If you start adding features
like Java A dot Kotlin,
things may very, obviously.
Now, if you look a little
deeper at performance,
things are a little
bit more complicated.
So in particular, when you
look at incremental builds,
you can see that Java C for a
full build was about 10% to 15%
of the overall build, but when
you went incremental build,
it jumps to a really bad 38%
of the overall build time.
So really, we can see that
in incremental scenarios,
Java C compilation is
the dominating factor.
Why is that?
It's because it's
not incremental.
Why is it not incremental?
It's because people are
using annotation processors,
and so far, they are
not incremental-capable.
So we started a joint
effort with Gradle
to have incremental
annotation processors.
It's called InCAP.
So it's ready.
It's been shipped in 4.7.
And now we are in
the process of trying
to move all of Google's
annotation processors
to be incremental-capable.
There is an action
required from you.
If you have in-house
annotation processors,
then you should move them
to be inCAP-capable to use
this library.
It's not very complicated.
For the simple
annotation processors
where there is just, like, one
source file and it generates
something from one
source, there's
a need to see the entire world.
It's just adding a few manifest
entries, so it's very simple.
And that will, if all of
your annotation processors
are inCAP-capable, be able
to switch the compilation
to be incremental,
and that will have
a huge impact on the performance
of your incremental builds.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Let's talk a little
bit about Jetpack.
You've heard about it a
lot, so how does it work?
Let's just take
the first example
where you want to move
to a pure androidx.
project.
So here, you've got
your old project.
It's using the old
[INAUDIBLE] support.
What you should do is to use
the refactoring tool in studio
to actually move your
project to use the new stuff.
One of the issues is that
we add some dependencies
to your project automatically,
so you use legacy multi-dex
or you use data binding.
We're going to add automatically
the multi-dex support library.
Now, if you move to
a new pure androidx.
world, Where you now
suddenly have the androidx.
constraint layout instead
of the old com.support, we
need to know that we must
use the word androidx.
multi-dex runtime library so
that the two worlds do not
collide, right?
So we need to have an indication
of which one we want to inject.
And you need to tell to
plug-in through this flag which
of the two versions
you want us to use, OK?
So if you want to
move to an androidx.
world, please use this flag.
If you are in a
hybrid world, which
is most likely what's going
to happen to most people--
so yes, you've moved
your application,
you moved all your projects
to use the new androidx.
Stuff, but you use
some external library
that you have no control
over, that still uses
the old com.support
libraries, you
have no control over the
sources, so what can you do?
So we're going to provide
a build time translation
facility that will just
basically change automatically
the dependency from the
old [INAUDIBLE] support
to the new one, and will
change the library itself
by changing all the import
statements to the new ones.
So this is done locally.
It's not like we're going
to republish this library.
But locally, you
will be able to have
an illusion of a pure world
where everybody is depending
on the new androidx.
Library.
Again, there is a
flag-enabled Jetifier.
XAVIER DUCOY: OK, so let's
talk about the app bundle.
I'm sure you've heard
about the app bundle a lot
over the last two days,
so we're going to tell you
a few greater, specific things.
So the first thing is that
on the application plug-in--
not on the library or
the feature plug-in,
but on the application
plug-in, on top
of all the assemble
tasks that you see here,
we have bundled tasks.
And so you'll be able to very
quickly, without any change,
just go and build a bundle.
And remember that the bundle
is a way to upload that
to the Play Store and
get out-of-the-box,
much smaller APKs
targeting API, density,
and languages for
a specific device.
So you'll get much
smaller [INAUDIBLE]..
Locally, you can also
build an APK exactly
the same way the Play Store does
it when it creates those APK.
So if you want to
verify something,
saying, you know,
I have a device,
I don't want to build
an APK directly,
I want to build an
APK the way the Play
Store would create an APK from
the bundle, you can do that.
So this step is definitely
a little bit more
involved than directly
building the APK, right?
We first build a
bundle, then we use
a tool called Bundle tool, which
is also available as a command
line tool, to create a ZIP
of all possibility cases,
and then based on a
device configuration,
we can go and create those APKs.
In general, we don't
really necessarily want
you to create that manually
using a greater task.
However, a lot of Studio
Android itself can
use that flow when you need it.
So for example,
the install task,
if you have just a basic
Android application
with no dynamic features, is
going to directly build an APK.
As soon as you create
dynamic features, which
we'll talk about
in a little bit,
then the install task
will go through the bundle
in order to ensure that we can
install that on any device.
Because remember, if you
have a dynamic feature
and you try to install
on a pre-L device, so API
less than 21, we need to
fuse those APKs together
in order to install
it, and we don't
want to do it a way that's
different from the Play Store.
We want to do it
exactly the same way
the Play Store does it.
If you try to run test from
the command line calling
connected check,
it's always going
to go directly to the APKs.
We're going to work
later on adding support
to run test [INAUDIBLE]
the bundle in order
to simulate better exactly
the type of APKs that
are created by the Play Store.
Deploying from Studio,
you have a choice, right?
You can either
directly deploy APKs
or you can deploy APKs
[INAUDIBLE] the bundle.
And here, the run
configuration inside Studio
has a checkbox
that you can check.
We recommend to not
check it when you
do your regular development.
As we saw earlier, building
an APK from the bundle
is much complicated than
building it directly.
And on top of that, when
you deploy from Studio,
we actually look at the
device you want to target,
and then we inject that
information into Gradle,
and then Gradle
takes some shortcuts.
So for example, if you require
legacy multi-dex, which
takes a while to build,
but you deploy it
to device that's
21 or above, we're
actually going to use
[INAUDIBLE],, which
is much faster.
We can't take that kind
of shortcut when we build
a bundle, so we recommend to
have two different types of run
configuration, just
create two of them--
one with and one
without the option--
and then use the APK as often
as you can, and only use
the other one when
you really have
to, when you want to try exactly
the APK that will be delivered
by the Play Store.
If you push to a device,
again, that's pre-21,
then we're going to use
that option any way,
and we're always going
to go through the bundle,
as soon as you have
dynamic features.
So you may already be doing
manual multi-APK using the DSL,
and also, there's
a variant API that
allows you to compute
version code dynamically
for all the different
APKs that get generated.
If you're doing that
right now and you
want to switch to the
bundle, you can't just
erase all of that DSL.
It's completely
unnecessary, right?
There's nothing to do.
All you have to do-- you
call the bundle task,
get your bundle, you're done.
And on the server side, we will
do all the splits by density,
ABI long wedge by
default. We do have
a DSL to allow you to
maybe disable it if you're
running into a problem.
We expect that there will be
very, very few cases where
you actually need to do that,
but you have the ability
if you really have to.
If you have that,
also file a bug
and talk to the Play Store team
and see if you can actually
solve the problem with them.
So I mentioned dynamic
feature earlier.
So what are dynamic features?
They are smaller APKs that
are downloaded on-demand side
by side with your main APK.
So if you have a feature that
only 10% of all users need,
no need to install
it for the other 90%.
Just type in download on-demand.
So the way you're going
to organize your code
is it's a separate
sub-project in Gradle.
You have a different
plug-in, a new plug-in,
called dynamic
feature, and the layout
is a little bit different
compared to, let's say,
a library.
Normally, in a library,
your application depends
on your library and cannot
refer the code of the library.
Here, the features are
actually sitting on top
and depend on the base.
So we can see here the
two dynamic features
in blue applying the
plug-in Dynamic Feature.
Have a dependency on the project
app, which is your base one.
Now, the base one
also has to refer
to those dynamic features.
It needs to list them
because the way we build--
I'll show you later.
It's a little bit
complicated, it's unusual.
But you need to list
those dynamic features,
and it's just a list
of strings which
are the greater path of all
of your dynamic features.
If you used Instant
App since last year,
it probably looks
somewhat similar.
You know, Instant App you have
the feature plug-in, which
is used both for your features
and for your base feature,
except you have a small flag
using base feature equals true.
But the base feature also has to
refer to all of those features
using a slightly different
DSL, which is not great,
and we'll probably migrate to
the Dynamic Feature version
soon, but right now, you
do it using the feature
configuration.
And you probably heard
that in the future,
you'll be able to Instant-enable
your app bundle in order
to deliver dynamic apps
using the app bundle,
and this is why it's going to
be possible, because the Feature
plug-in and the Dynamic Feature
plug-in are very, very similar.
In fact, the application Dynamic
Feature and Feature plug-in
share probably over
95% of their code.
They are extremely similar.
And so if you're already
architecturing your app
for Instant App, switching
to the app bundle
would be exactly the same
architecture with slightly
different plug-ins.
And if you're doing
Dynamic Feature right now,
then also enabling that
to be done in Instant App
would be very similar
in the future.
OK, so I mentioned that
bidirectional dependency
where the app bundle
needs to know about--
the base app needs to
know about the feature.
So if you have those two
modules that I had before,
if you're building the APK,
just looks normal, right?
There's a bunch of
intermediates in each module,
and each output an APK.
What happens is that the bundle
task belongs to the app module.
And so when you actually
build the bundle,
we have to publish things
from the Feature back
into the base module,
and that's why
we need to have all
of those dependencies
be available on the base module.
If you don't add a dynamic
feature to your base module,
it's just not going to show
up in your bundle at all.
JEROME DOCHEZ: So when
developing dynamic features,
it's important to
understand there
are some differences with
traditional Android application
building.
In particular, there's
some attributes
of your application
which are invariant,
which won't change
between the base module
and the features--
application-id, versionName,
versionCode.
All of those should be
set in the base module,
and we will then publish
them back to the features
so that they can be
used in the task when,
for instance, generating
the manifest or whatever.
So it's important to understand
that you set them in the base,
you do not repeat
them in the features.
We will automatically
transfer them, OK?
Let's talk a little
bit about multi-dex.
So let's say you're in
a multi-dex situation
and you're not
using any features,
but you're still doing
the bundle thing.
In this case, there's
really not much difference.
It's the same behavior.
The only difference is that
instead of shipping stuff
into an APK, we are now shipping
into a bundle, which eventually
gets uploaded.
The dynamic delivery
will not do much.
They will just take
these dex files
and store them on the
device before execution.
So same behavior.
If you have Feature, still
not a lot of difference.
Basically, each feature
can develop and grow,
can become itself
multiple dex files.
Everything gets merged
onto the base module,
and then you get all packaged
inside the bundle again.
And, you know, same
thing as without Feature.
It gets delivered on the phone.
Not a big difference.
By default, we enable
the native multi-dexing.
Now, things get a little
bit more complicated
if your minSdk is below 21.
So if it's below 21, we need to
have the flexibility to still
deliver the application
in native multi-dex
if you are suddenly deploying
on a device which is 25,
but if you're
deploying on 15, now we
need to do something
specific for that.
And what will happen is
that a dynamic delivery
will fuse all of your dex
files into a single one that
will be delivered.
So this is important
to realize that even
if none of your modules,
including the base
module or your Feature
modules, if none of them
use multi-dexing itself,
because we combine those
into a single one,
this may actually
go over to the dex limit, and
this may require multi-dexing.
So you need to manually
enable multi-dex
in the base application.
And what that will
do is basically
create the maindex list that
it will ship along with all
the dex files into the bundle.
So now the dynamic delivery
will take that bundle,
and it will be capable
that, if suddenly you're
trying to deploy this
bundle on a 15 device,
it will use the maindex
list to do the fusing,
create the correct maindex, and
then create the [INAUDIBLE] dex
correctly, all right?
Shrinking and obfuscation.
So it's the same as before--
you set it on the base module,
just like the application ID.
So you say, minifyEnabled.
This is not a lot of changes,
but how we actually implement
it is really, really different.
So let's go through
the motion here.
First of all, this
is only supported
with R8, which is our
whole new shrinker I
talked about earlier.
So what we do is that we
take all the rules that
will be defined close to
the classes they apply to.
So we'll need the
rules in the features.
We're going to merge all
the rules into a single one.
Then we'll take all the class
files, we filled this into R8.
R8 will create a combined dex.
Big dex files with everything.
And then we're going to feed
that dex file into a dex
splitter, which will
re-split this dex for all
of the features
plus for the base.
So it's a very different
mechanism as before.
Now we have-- again, this
dex has been shrinked.
It's been obfuscated.
Now there's two
scenarios possible.
Either you're using the bundle
or you're using the APK.
If you're using the
bundle, it's pretty simple.
These dex files
are automatically
transferred into the
bundle like we saw earlier.
If you're using feature
it's slightly different.
The dex files need to
be republished back
to each of the feature.
And then they will be
packaged into the APKs.
Right?
So it's a slightly
different mechanism
as we must have
seen in the past.
There's a lot of
going back and forth,
and that's why we need to
have these dependencies
between features and app.
XAVIER DUCOY: OK,
so we wanted to talk
a little bit about a few
things that actually are not
shipping in 3.2.
We are working on it.
We've been working
on it for a while.
We expect they will ship soon--
you know, 3.3 Canary.
And they have a lot of changes.
And so we wanted to kind
of give you a heads up
and also we want feedback
as soon as it's available.
So I want to talk about the
way we process resources
right now in the boot.
So if you have a first
library or library two,
in the current flow
what happens is
that we're going to
process those resources
and we are just
going to generate
another java and nothing else.
So when these get consumed by
another library, library one,
this one may be referencing
resources from library two.
And so in order to really
validate all those resource
references, and also this
with some overlay mechanism,
we're going to merge
those two resource
folders into a single
resource folder
and process it, and then
generate another R class.
We actually generate
two R classes, right?
One is called the library
itself, library one,
which contains all the resources
from library one and library
two.
And then we have
another one, which
is just a new version
of the R class generated
by library two,
that is used in case
you want to run tests and things
like that you need the final ID
version of it.
So then that gets consumed
by an application.
We kind of have to do
the same thing again.
So we're going to re-merge the
app and library one, library
two, and process all of that.
And then we generate the final
resource binary format as well
as all our final classes
that are needed by the code
from the app, library
one and library two.
So as you can see, this is
not exactly efficient, right?
This is probably one
of the last thing
that is very inefficient
in the way we build things.
The resources from
library two is
basically merged and
processed three times.
We generate a lot
of our classes.
In fact, we're seeing some
projects with a few hundred
modules generating
several thousands
of classes, which is too many.
And so we really
need to solve this.
So as I said, we've been
working on a new flow
and this is what the
new flow looks like.
So first, when we
compile the library two
we're going to generate a
binary version of resources.
And this is because
AAPT2 has that feature.
We can't make that
work with AAPT,
so that's why Jerome was
saying, AAPT is going away.
AAPT2 is really the future.
We also create the R class.
And this time we just integrate
the R class directly rather
than just source code so that
we don't have to compile it.
That's more efficient.
When we depend on
it and consume it
in library one, what
we're going to do
is that we are only
going to process
the resources of that module.
And then we use the output
of the previous module
the same way, basically, you
use a jar during Java C, right?
It's just a compile test class.
It's mostly there to validate
again resource references
and regenerate a new
resource package that
only contains those resources.
Not the merge version.
There's no merge anymore.
And the R class only
of that library.
Now, that library R class
only contain the resources
of that library.
It does not contain the resource
IDs of the previous library
and this one.
We don't know merge
those IDs anymore.
When an app depends on
library one and library
two, same exact principles.
At the end, we have
an additional step
because we need to
take all those binaries
and binary format
of the resources
and merge it into the final one
and create the final R class.
So as you can see, we're merging
everything a lot less classes.
And also it's a
lot more efficient.
For example if I change
a resource in library two
by just editing,
let's say, a string,
there's no reason that I need
to compile library one again.
Right, it's just
the list of ideas
that I need to check
against for reference
is exactly the same
one as with no changes.
So we can use the same thing,
like combination avoidance
that we use for Java C.
And then we don't need
to recompile every one.
We don't need to recompile
the app [INAUDIBLE]..
All we have to do is do the
final link, and that's it.
And we can do that also because
the outlasts for the app
does not use final IDs anymore.
So let's look at some of
the impact of that change.
So first I said that the
R class of each module
only contain the
resources of that module.
It doesn't contain all of them.
That means that if
you're inside a module
and you want to reference
another resource
from another module,
you have to use the R
class from that module instead
of the R class of your app.
That means you're likely to
have to import more than one R
class, which is [INAUDIBLE]
solved easily with [INAUDIBLE]..
We're looking at ways to
make that work in Java
easily, because
technically there's
no reason for the R
class to be called R. It
could be called whatever else.
So each library would
define its own name
to reduce the
amount of conflicts.
And again as I said, you know
the R class IDs are not final
anymore, even in [INAUDIBLE]
out to inside libraries, which
means that you can't use
Java switch cases anymore.
I mentioned that we are not
doing resource measure anymore.
So if you have a module that
redefined a resource already
present in your library, that's
not going to work anymore.
And there's some
good reason for that.
We definitely want to
hear from you, if you are
using that in a strange way.
If what you're
doing is when you're
debugging my app I want to
overwrite an icon that's
coming from one
of my library, you
can just use variant aware
dependency management, right?
In that library you have a
debug version of that icon,
and then the app will consume
the debug question anyway,
which was not the
case before 3.0.
So that solves that problem.
If you have another
use case, definitely
talk to us because we
want to hear about it.
So I mentioned namespace, right?
You know, I haven't talked
about any namespace so far.
But when you think
about it, you know
I just said we don't have any
resource merger or resource
pavilion.
So what happens is
your application
depends on a third party library
here or a third party library
here, and both of them declare
exactly the same resource
with the same name, but
with a different value.
You know, a string midi
or a layout or [INAUDIBLE]
or something like that.
In the past, the
resource manager
would just pick one
of them, basically.
The first one that you
find your dependency
would have a higher
priority, and it would just
merge on top of the other
one it each would just
replace the other one, which
is probably not what you want.
And so here what's
happening now is
that what we really
want to do is we
want to package both of them.
So both of them are
going to be compiled
in their own namespace.
And then we're going
to package that.
Internally, the R classes
from those two libraries
will have different--
will have the same R.string.foo,
but with different values.
And internally, the
resource stabilizer, they we
really point to two
different resources which
is much better so now
when you reference
to a resource from
a library, you
have to use the namespace
of that library.
And using the R
class of that library
is already a way to access
the site's namespace, right?
It's like you don't
have a secure R
class with all the IDs.
So when you do that
from the manifest,
it's a little bit different.
You have to use the manifest--
when you start from XML you have
to use the namespace directly
in the resources.
So add colon dot library
one, colon strings-fixed,
which is very similar now to
when you access an Android.
Namespace resource, right?
At Android colon something.
If you do have
custom attributes,
you have to do same thing.
So you're probably using res
auto everywhere now, not really
bothering what
your limb space is.
Now you actually have to care.
You can say, hey, you know
this is construct layout,
this XML prefix constraint is
that namespace of that library.
And then I can use
those attributes.
So we're hoping to
bring in 3.3 Canary.
It's going to be opt-in.
Obviously some breaking changes.
We're going to label
that with a flag.
We're going to include
refactoring support in studio,
so that you know all
those references will
be changed for you.
And we're going to want
a lot of feedback, right?
It's not going to be turned
on in 3.3 Final by default.
Either there's going to be
several revisions where there
will be changes and improvement,
but we want a lot of feedback.
JEROME DOCHEZ: OK, last
thing we want to talk
about today is our public API.
We are painfully aware that
the public API that we provide
is not very good.
It has very poor documentation.
The plugin DSL is very bad.
It's not specific
to the module type,
so there's plenty
of things to kind
of set in different modules,
yet the DSL is still there.
There's no mechanism to
access the intermediate files.
So some people would like to
have access to the [INAUDIBLE]
manifest, class files,
dex files when they make,
you can't really do
it in a nice way.
The variant model doesn't give
access to a lot of information
coming from the
variant properties.
So you only have access to
part of the [? Truth. ?]
And then there's just too
many things that require
internal APIs, hacking tasks.
The separation between
public and internal API
is not well defined,
so you don't
know when you're switching
from one to the other.
So it's a mess.
And to give you an example,
this is how the configuration
works today, right?
So we have the
DSL parsing first,
and then we create
a variant, right?
A bunch of variants are created
and we create all the tasks
that go to those variants.
And eventually we
call the variant API.
So that's where a lot of
these customization scripts
are running.
But you can see here the
problem is right there.
It's right in front of you.
It's happening after the
tasks have been created.
So there's no way you
can change anything that
will influence tasks creation.
Say you want to switch
from legacy multidex
to native multidex?
You don't do that anymore,
because we've already created
the tasks for legacy multidex.
Say you want to change some
of the information in the DSL
programmatically instead
of putting it in the DSL?
You can't really do that
either, because we already
created the tasks and chances
are that the inputs have
already been finalized.
So it's happening
too late, and then
eventually the
[INAUDIBLE] evaluate
scripts, the custom
ones, run even later.
So there's really no way you
can do a lot of things here.
And so what people do is that
they access the tasks and then
they try to figure out where
the files are generated
and it's a mess.
So what we would like to do
is to have a simple Gradle API
interface that would be
the only module that you
should depend on.
And if you start depending
on some of our older modules
like other call, you
should talk to us
and you should tell us
what are your needs.
Why are you doing this?
Don't think that we
are not listening.
We are interested
in figuring out
why you need to
customize things,
and we are interested in
providing you a good solution.
So one of the things we
are looking for instance
is to give you access to all
of the intermediate files.
So each intermediate file really
is associated with a type,
right?
You've got classes, you've
got merged manifest,
you've got dex files,
you've got resources.
All of those should
be able to be accessed
and should be safely
capable of being replaced.
So you should be able to say,
give me the merged manifest,
change it a little
bit, and I'm giving you
back this new version.
And that's the
one you should use
to continue the build process.
So it should be replaceable.
It should be appendable.
Maybe you want to add
class files directly.
And eventually
all of this should
be done through very
well-defined extension points.
So we started working
on it, and we would
like to have feedbacks on this.
So the proposed phases
would be slightly different.
Now you've got a DSL parsing.
We would then start invoking
your custom code right there.
So you would have
the ability to stop
changing DSL objects
programmatically,
even before we start
creating variants.
Then we would lock them up.
That means you can't
change them anymore.
Once that code has
run, it's locked up.
We would then create variants
from this information.
From the variant we can then
code directly to variant API.
So that's the ability
for you to change
variant-related information.
Now be aware that this is
happening now before the tasks
creation, right?
There's no tasks created yet.
So this is really the ability
to say, it was using multidex,
now I want it to
use legacy multidex.
Once these scripts have
run, we will lock up
the variant object.
So again, if you use [INAUDIBLE]
scripts on like enough
to evaluate, that starts
to change the DSL parsing
of the variant, it's too late.
We will not allow it
with one exception.
Then eventually
we create the task
and we will lock
them up immediately.
We will not allow you to
modify the tasks anymore.
The way to modify
things would be
to go through the
buildable artifact,
to inject, to
replace, to append,
but not mucking with the tasks.
Because we replace
them all the time.
We merge them, we delete
them, we split them,
whatever we need to do
to support new features
or make things more efficient.
And then eventually the
after evaluate will run.
So the compatibility will
be a painful subject.
We will try to make obviously
the DSL mostly unchanged.
We're going to try to make
an effort to also becoming
more Kotlin-friendly.
And unfortunately we
think that the variant API
will change heavily.
But since we already realized
that it was not so great,
hopefully you would be
sympathetic to the idea
that you would have to
change the script using
the variant API.
So we want to hear from you.
It's very important
that we get feedback
from the community for us.
And I want to thank
you for coming tonight.
I know it's late session.
It was very nice to see so
many people here tonight.
Thank you.
XAVIER DUCOY: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]